information from all three spiders into  these 15 genetically designed super  spiders there's 14 I beg your pardon  ones missing  I guess the research is working on that  one do you know that this is the largest  electron microscope on the eastern  seaboard  you were talking throughout that woman's  entire presentation so talk about how we  listen  I don't know what it's like those fancy  private school  hey Kai take your picture I need one  with a student in it sure yeah  great where do you want me Oh over here  yeah yeah that's great  don't make me look ugly that's  impossible  perfect  okay great  that's great  MJ let's go wait Thanks  [Music]  [ __ ] let's do it  [Music]  you